[Musique]
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il est
en détention
je serai jugé dans mes jours et un de
leurs agents étant en route pour
rassembler des preuves
tu as huit jours
la trace
tu dois effacer leur existence
il est mort pas mal
je crois qu'on a un problème parce que
tu es la preuve qui le fera tomber
il faut qu'on retrouve checker les vies
sont en danger vous pourriez nous aider
à la trouver
ça fait un bail que j'attendais de
revenir ici Jake
l'homme qui vous traque est un tueur
professionnel
je suis là pour vous protéger
du calme où est le gamin
[Musique]
il nous tuera tous pour vous atteindre
vous savez ce qu'on éteint ok
on va se le faire
si on y retourne en direct
je ne devrais pas avoir à vivre ça